alright guys bangbang I've got Brent
here many of you probably do not know
Brent and it's unfortunate because he
has been calling a lot of what's playing
out now in the markets for for quite a
while now so thanks so much for jumping
on and recording this
yeah I'm looking forward to talking to
you it's gonna be fun for sure so let's
just get started maybe let's go through
your background real quick so people
understand the perspective that you're
coming at this with and then we'll jump
into the dollar milkshake theory sure so
I've got a firm called Santiago capital
which long story short it's a wealth
management firm I work with a little
over a dozen individuals and families
helping them design and in then you know
implement and manage their investment
portfolios and you know it's kind of
comprehensive we customized it to
everybody so it's kind of a high level
of service in addition to that I run a
private fund which is focused on a
number of knock-on effects based on a
theory that I have where the dollars
going to get stronger over the next
couple years and that that fund plays as
a portion of my clients overall
portfolios so I been in the wealth
management business for a little over 20
years I started with a firm called
Donaldson Lufkin & Jenrette in New York
City in 99 I moved with them to San
Francisco in 2000 was with credit Swiss
for ten years through the global
financial crisis at which point I had a
let's just called a disagreement with my
superiors on whether I was a fiduciary
for my clients or whether I was a
salesman for credit Swiss and ultimately
I decided that wasn't the right place
for me and to be honest I'm not sure if
they were too upset to see me go but you
know I wanted to continue in the
business and I wanted to do it at an
independent platform where I felt I
could do the right thing for clients and
it wasn't so much commission based and
it wasn't a transaction based business
and it wasn't you know who or I could
actually look out for the best of my
clients as opposed to
not for the best of my firm so to speak
or at least align those you get those
incentives aligned a little bit better
so I joined a friend of mine he had a
firm called Baker Avenue asset
management I joined there a few years
later I set up Santiago capital which
was used to do some alternative
investing some precious metals investing
I've since transitioned my entire
business under Santiago capital
I still have an affiliation with Baker
Avenue been great partners for me and
still sit with them and talk with them
every day except for when we're in
quarantine but that's kind of my
evolution in the business I've really
kind of focused on the big picture I
look at macro trends I try to figure out
what's going to happen and you know
asset class to asset class and country
to country currency to currency as
opposed to trying to you know I don't
get too involved in the balance sheets
of individual companies that we invest
in you know I have some colleagues who
do that so I focus on the big picture
and try if I figure if I can get the big
picture right the the little picture
will hopefully take care of itself
got it and so where did the name
Santiago Capital come from well that's a
little bit it's a good question I always
like to hear how other people come up
with their names as well it turns oh
eyyy several years ago before I start on
Wall Street I did this trip across Spain
called the Camino de Santiago which is
an ancient pilgrimage route Christian
pilgrimage route so I walked 500 miles
across Spain and it was just a fantastic
experience and then combine that with
the the lead character in my two
favorite books his name Santiago so when
I was coming up with the you know trying
to figure out what I was gonna call my
company it just I kept coming back to
that and I kept trying to think of other
ones and I just kept coming back to
Santiago and I finally just said you
know don't don't don't fight it just
embrace it so but that's that's where
we're at
that's how the best names come together
so help you understand the dollar
milkshake theory because you've been
kind of explaining this and pushing this
for a while we've seen it you know
really play out how you called it what
exactly is that dollar milkshake theory
well so first of all I'll say I
appreciate you saying that I've called
it right I don't know if I've called it
completely right but it's on the right
track somebody asked me the other day
where they thought I was at 'you know
using a football analogy and i said i
thought i was just over mid field maybe
around the 40 or 45 you know it's it's
heading in the right direction so far
it's playing out the way we thought it
would play out but this is a big game
and it's a long game and I you know I I
don't have any illusions that it's going
to be easy from here on out it's
probably gonna be pretty challenging but
I think the opportunities are enormous
essentially without all started a very
big picture level then I'll try to get
more detailed on the dollar milkshake
theory but essentially what it is is I
think that we're gonna go through the
biggest short squeeze in history and
what I mean by that is I think the US
dollar is going to get squeezed much
much higher and it's going to get
squeezed much much higher because
despite the fact that many people don't
like it would prefer to have an
alternative that they just don't and the
rest of the world in well the US and the
rest of the world has taken out an
incredible amount of u.s. dollar debt
that debt either gets paid off serviced
or defaulted on and the only way that
that isn't extremely dollar positive as
if it gets paid off I don't see how it
can get paid off there's just not enough
dollars to go around but the demand just
to continue to service it continues to
put a bit under the dollar and if it
gets defaulted on defaults while it
maker decrease demand it actually
destroys money and what I mean by that
is in a debt based monetary system where
money gets loaned into existence a
default actually makes money disappear
and it starts a chain reaction all the
way back to the collateral which was the
original basis of which everything was
loaned into existence so even if you
have defaults where demand Falls supply
Falls even faster so whether people
continue using the dollar and are able
to service it I think that puts a bit
under it or if they start defaulting on
it because they can't pay it or don't
want to pay it we get a supply shock and
the dollar goes higher I can't figure
out a scenario actually I
can figure out a couple potential
scenarios where it would go lower but I
just think those are very low level
probabilities and because I'm so adamant
about it or because I'm so convinced of
it that's probably why I've been as
that's why I've been pounding the table
on it as much as I have not so much
because I want to be right I mean don't
get me wrong I want to be right you know
I'm I'm in this to make money
I'd be clear that's my job my job is to
make money I want to be right and I want
to make money but one of the reasons but
if I just wanted to make money I'd just
be quiet and you know not say anything
but one of the reasons I'm as vocal as I
am about it is I think it's one of the
biggest problems existing today and I
actually want to help people I want to
help people understand what's happening
so that they can understand how maybe
they can position their purse their self
as we go through this and even if they
don't believe in it and even if they
don't agree with it at least if parts of
it become true they can kind of
understand why it's happening and so
that's that's kind of the that's kind of
the that's kind of the genesis of the
idea that's it's why I think it's such
an important idea and it's why I've been
so vocal about it got it and I've heard
you describe kind of the actual
milkshake component of it as you know
other countries injecting liquidity and
kind of making the milkshake but the
u.s. rather than having the ability to
inject the liquidity having a straw
maybe kind of covered that so I think
it's a really good way of articulating
this plays out yeah so I'm happy to
answer that and I'll say it's really
interesting that you asked this at this
point because over the last call it well
especially over the last couple months
and definitely over the last year I've
been accused of changing my story and
it's funny because on one hand I get
accused of changing my story and then on
the other hand I get accused of being so
stubborn and never being open to new
ideas so it's it's a little bit of a
mixture there but when this initially
started a couple years ago I initially I
should tell you I used to run a gold
fund and and I don't have time to go
through the whole story of why I used to
run it and why I no longer run it but
essentially I ended up shutting it down
because I was not able to raise enough
capital to make the fund structure
through which I was running it
economically
it was too expensive for clients and I
didn't think it was the appropriate
thing to do so we shut it down we still
own a gold for clients but we don't own
it in this structure anymore and part of
the reasons I shut down is I didn't
think or I did a big big study on the
dollar and gold because I was trying to
figure out why was gold staying in this
bear market I most of my my my thoughts
were that gold should be going higher
and the dollar should be going lower and
it just wasn't and I fought it for a
long time I was very stubborn and
finally I just said to myself something
I'm missing here yeah I got to figure
this out and so I kind of did this big
deep dive on my thesis and to be honest
I didn't like the answer I came up with
because the answer I came up with was
that the dollar was going to go a lot
higher and typically in the gold world
one of the core tenets of being a gold
investors you think the dollar is going
to zero and so what what what was also
interesting is the more I studied it the
more I could became convinced that the
dollar would go higher but I also
thought the gold would go higher with it
I thought there might be an interim
period where the dollar would rise gold
would fall but I became more convinced
than ever that we'd get to a period
where they would rise together and so as
I started doing all this work on the
dollar and what I thought the dollar was
going to go get hot and get higher the
more I got into it the more it became
clear to me and that's when the the
milkshake analogy came up because
there's this famous movie called there
will be blood I don't know if you've
ever seen it but it's about this oil
baron this really cruel oil baron and
he's just ruthless I mean he'll just do
anything to get one up on his
competitors and kind of at the end of
the movie he's talking to one of his
competitors and his competitor says you
know I'm not gonna sell my oil to you
and he says well it doesn't matter I'm
just gonna stick I'm gonna stick a straw
you know across your fence down into
your ground and I'm gonna suck it all up
you know so whether you give it to me or
not I'm gonna drink your milkshake
is essentially what he says and the more
I started studying the the global
monetary system and where I thought
capital flows would go over the next
couple
the more I can became convinced that due
to a number of factors the US was going
to suck that capital into the United
States so it didn't matter where that
capital originated it could be on my
side of the fence to the other side of
the fence all I got to do is stick a
straw down in there to all that
liquidity and suck it up and so what I
how that related to the dollar milkshake
theory that I was talking about in in my
world as opposed to this this movie was
that over the last 10 years I since the
global financial crisis we all know that
the Fed came out and did QE in these
bailouts and they pumped the economy
full of liquidity right but it wasn't
solely a u.s. phenomenon you know the
Bank of England did it the ECB did it
the BOJ did it the Chinese that are ever
in Canada you know build out their
housing market so the whole world got
behind this injection of liquidity and
for the first five years we all did it
in unison from 2000 call it nine to two
thousand fourteen or fifteen everybody
was injecting it was a coordinated
monetary policy but in 2015 the u.s.
stopped and the u.s. started raising
interest rates and when they raised it
the first time I was pretty skeptical
but when they raised it the first time
and the market didn't crash because a
lot of people thought as soon as they
raised interest rates the market was
gonna crash and I was probably initially
maybe not completely on board that but I
would not have been surprised if that
happened but when it didn't happen
that's when I really kind of started
when I said I did this to kind of deep
dive and and what I decided was that
there actually was one scenario under
which we could continue to raise rates
even though the rest of the world wasn't
and so I thought that over the next
couple years that we would get rate
hikes and so that's when I started
talking about as we rate as we as we
take our syringe away and we no longer
inject liquidity we stick a straw ton in
there and as we raise interest rates
that pulls capital in the United States
now that was the analogy I used much
most because that was the predominant
reason that I thought capital would flow
into the US was interest rates but
that's not the only reason there's many
reasons that I thought capital would
flow into the United States
one was you know Trump Trump was a big
part of this Trump did a lot of
deregulation made it more attractive for
capital to come in he did a number of
tax deals which made it a tractive place
for capital the fact that we were
growing faster than the rest of the
world or in many other places of the
world you know look at the especially in
Silicon Valley it made it a very
attractive place for capital flow and I
just you know the and because it's the
world reserve currency people have to
use the dollar for transactions it place
is kind of a natural bid under the
dollar if you're gonna hold reserves and
you can hold them and you it makes sense
to hold it in the dollar well then why
not also hold you know Treasury bonds or
US real estate or US asset prior stocks
so for all those reasons I thought that
the US would suck that capital into the
United States now in 2000 was at 18 I'm
gonna get my ears messed up here a
little bit maybe it was 19 anyway I
thought with it so we got nine interest
rate hikes most people didn't think we
would get one or two and but we got nine
of them and you know the whole way up
people were saying that's gonna crash
the economy it's gonna crash the economy
well it finally did and I actually
thought that we would get a couple more
interest rate hikes than we did but I
was wrong you know it we didn't get
those last two or three that I thought
we would get and I and I kind of
admitted it fairly quickly I said you
know what I was wrong their change in
their tune you know Powell kind of did a
180 stopped the quantitative tightening
but even though they stopped the
quantitative tightening and they
actually started lowering interest rates
it didn't mean that we were not still an
attractive place for all those other
reasons that I mentioned and I kind of
got to a place I have this channel of
the sp500 that I've been following for
well since 2009 really and in it and
it's usually kind of bounced around in
that channel but went higher and we got
to the very top of that channel and
actually peaked our head out of the top
of the channel a little bit and I kind
of thought we'd kind of overdone it I
thought we would get a pullback now I
didn't think we would get this big of a
pullback I thought we might get a 10%
pullback I would 15% pullback I wasn't
quite expecting a 25 or 30 percent
pullback but here we are
and now everybody's printing the whole
world is printing we're printing but
this and then people will say to me well
isn't this gonna kill the dollar well if
we were act again if we were acting in a
vacuum it absolutely would but this is
also very similar to 2009 when we
announced QE 1 & 2 & 3 back in you know
10 years ago a number of institutions
and people around the world thought that
the United States dollar would fall as a
result of that if you think the dollar
is gonna fall one of the smart things to
do is you take debt out in that currency
and as it gets inflated away you pay it
back at a lower price later on well the
rest of the world borrowed thirteen
trillion dollars in u.s. dollars I think
it was around four or five trillion in
2008 and now it's another 10 trillion
since then nine for nine or ten trillion
since then but the problem is is that
the dollar didn't get weaker over that
time the dollar actually got stronger
over that time and so now we're back in
the same situation we owe a lot of debt
but the rest of the world owes 13
trillion of a currency that they can't
print and we're in a situation where
asset prices are falling and it's crits
when when we talked about asset prices
following it makes money disappear
because when money is loaned into
existence and you have defaults money
gets destroyed so now you still have
this high level of debts that need to be
paid off but the supply of dollars is
shrinking it's deflation right and so
we're going through a massive
deleveraging event right now and so now
all the central banks of the world again
are coming out and printing like crazy
and listen the the Fed is printing like
a madman I'm not denying it but the ECB
is - the Bank of Canada is - China is -
Australia is - do Brasil is - everybody
so now we're back to this coordinated
effect again right everybody's providing
liquidity I just happen to believe that
it doesn't really matter where that
liquidity gets injected whoever has the
straw gets to suck up that liquidity now
on a relative basis despite the fact
that we've cut rates all the way down
they're still basically the highest in
the world you know other than maybe
China and again I don't think people are
racing to put money into China right
I don't think the you know the Russian
ruble is going to become the world
reserve currency anytime soon right so
while our rates are certainly not as
high as they were two years ago on a
relative basis they still look pretty
good but all those other factors are
still attractive for capital to come
into the United States and I think the
fact that we are still the world reserve
currency combined with those other
factors will draw capital in the United
States over the next couple years and I
think drawing in that capital will keep
the dollar stronger than other fiat
currencies despite that we're printing
so much of it so I know they're ramped
this for a long time right there but I
hope that makes sense
yeah there's two key pieces that I
really want to kind of touch on the
first is this idea that it's all a
relative argument right so even if rates
go down if there's still the highest
rates you still get the straw same thing
goes on the brightening side even if
you're printing money if you're kind of
in a more advantageous position than
everyone else you still get the straw
right and so there's kind of almost like
one straw everyone else has to inject
liquidity and then whoever has that
strong gets all of the flows and so your
argument basically is a relative basis
the u.s. still has that straw but then
the second piece of verse which I think
is interesting and I don't think I
understood this before you just
mentioned it is it's not binary the US
can have the straw and still be
injecting liquidity at the same time
right we can be putting with unity into
the system by printing money etc but we
can also be sucking the liquidity from
everywhere else into a dollar and that
appears what's happening right now
correct that that's my argument and I
think that's what will happen over the
next two or three years we're gonna mix
our own milkshake but we're also gonna
drink everybody else's okay and so help
me understand what is the impact kind of
forward-looking here if that theory
holds true and so far it seems to be
that's what's happening in this
liquidity crisis and the dollar
strengthening you cetera what's the
impact on equities and commodities and
then even other foreign currencies do we
just see oh that everything continue to
bleed out and the dollar strengthened
against it or something else happen well
let me let me qualify this by saying
this is not going to happen in a
straight line this is you know nothing
happens in a straight line there's going
to be fits and starts
there's going to be ups and there's
going to be pull backs but in general
over the next couple years what I think
will happen is I don't know if we found
the bottom and equities yet or not
III own equities I'm long equities I
think two or three years from now
equities will be much higher than they
are right now not because things are
good in the world and not because things
are good in the US but because they're
bad and we will be a recipient of flows
as a relative not an absolute but as a
relative safe haven so I think two or
three years from now due to all the
money printing and due to the effects of
that and the facts of sucking in the
money printing from around the world
will push us asset prices higher I think
it will push US stocks higher I think it
will allow us to fund our budget deficit
even though you know I think the rest of
the world is gonna have budget deficits
as well but I think we will be able to
fund our budget deficit easier than the
rest of the world we'll be able to fund
theirs again it doesn't mean that it's
gonna be perfect it doesn't mean that's
going to be easy but I think that will
allow us to happen and as as that
happens I think that keeps a bit under
the dollar I think the dollar goes
higher and I think it continues to put
incredible pressure on the rest of the
world because they have this dollar debt
that they have to service and you know
global commerce takes place in dollars
so you know I've used this example
before but if there's a Peruvian gold
mine that's selling gold to China
the and it's financed by a bacon bank in
Japan the invoices back and forth
between the three are probably in
dollars you know it that's just what you
know or copper or whatever it is you
know when we gets sent to China these
all take place in dollars because that's
the global reserve currency so whether
or not countries like the dollar it
doesn't really matter until there's a
viable opportunity otherwise that can be
used on a global scale
you know I think the dollar gets a bit
now it doesn't mean that things like
Bitcoin won't go up it doesn't mean that
gold won't go higher maybe there's some
other altcoins or stable coins or you
know maybe you know country start to
issue digital coins of their own that do
well but until something can replace the
global reserve system or the global
of currency system and there's another
country that can enforce its use the
dollar is still going to be the
predominant currency and so right it
becomes this big vicious circle whereas
the dollar gets a bid and us at process
of asset prices come up I think we get
those flows because we come more
attractive that flow of liquidity that
means that the rest of the world is Dean
being denied liquidity so they continue
to have pressure on them but it could
also be that we start to because now
we've got supply shortages whether its
food or mines shut down and minerals and
steel and other commodities aren't as in
abundance you know but the US still
needs them maybe there are some
inflationary effects and some but that's
not necessarily good for emerging
markets either because now maybe their
input costs are going up or they're you
know typically in emerging markets or
less developed economies food is more
expensive more bigger percent of their
overall budget and as food prices start
to rise their you know their cost of
living goes up but they're in a
depressed economy so their revenues so
they're getting squeezed from both sides
and as they get squeezed I think that
liquidity gets squeezed out of those
countries and it flows back too and
again it creates this vicious cycle and
it ends really badly for everybody
including the United States but I think
I think before that happens we get this
big short squeeze in the dollar and I
was talking to somebody else and I said
anybody who's ever seen a short squeeze
will never or have been involved in a
short scoop we'll never forget it
because you just cannot believe how high
the price of that thing goes it's just
amazing and then you never forget the
other side of it because it just crashes
afterwards as well like short squeezes
don't go from like Tesla it went from
400 to a thousand and outs back at 400
it doesn't go from 400 to 4,000 and stay
at 4,000 that never happens you get the
big you know ramped up and then you get
the crash and I kind of think that same
thing will happen with the dollar I
think we're gonna get this big short
squeeze on the dollar over the next
couple years it's gonna go higher than
anybody believes possible it's gonna
create chaos everywhere eventually the
world will come together they will do
something I don't know if they have
another Plaza Accord
it's written down or it's devalued or
you know the world says you know we were
Gold's now at seven thousand dollars
because of all the chaos that it's
caused and you know I don't know how
they're gonna do it but eventually this
will all reverse and then the dollar
will have a big slide the US will lose
all the capital flows the rest of the
world will start to receive the capital
flows and they will inflate while we
deflate so I I kind of see it like a
teeter-totter I think I think over the
next couple years we'll be going down
while there or will be going up while
they're going down and then it'll all
flip and it'll go back the other way
that's a very simplistic way of saying
it but that's kind of how I see it
playing out got it so that makes a lot
of sense now one of the things that it
makes me immediately think of so right
now we're seeing in this liquidity
crisis is everyone is selling any asset
they possibly can into a liquid market
to get dollars right we're seeing the
dollar strengthened that you're seeing
these commodities Bitcoin everything's
going down there is a number of people
who would argue and I'm actually
probably one of them that would say in
order for those asset prices to
stabilize and eventually recover you
need to have some weakening of the
dollar at some point you've got a pretty
interesting theory around the dollar
itself can strengthen and so could the
asset price of say gold or other assets
at the same time maybe uh unpack kind of
the nuance there between what is more
theoretical I think and you know
weakening the dollar asset prices
recovering versus maybe they all could
go up at the same time yeah so there's a
couple parts to this and this is the
part where I probably get challenged on
the most there's a you know there's a
lot of people who think the dollar is
gonna go lower there's you know I think
there's a lot more people that think
it's gonna go lower than higher but you
know you could argue that there's a lot
of people who think it's gonna go higher
but most of the people that think the
dollar is going to go higher also thinks
that's going to lead to just a
depression in the United States as well
and that's where I kind of disagree and
and I think that we're gonna get into a
situation and we'll listen we're not
there yet
but I think we're gonna get into a
situation where US asset prices rise the
US dollar Rises perhaps even I'm gonna
people are gonna think I'm crazy
interest rates might rise a little bit
and we will have some inflationary
effects in the United States even though
the dollar is getting higher a lot of
people equate the dollar losing value
with inflation and of course that makes
sense
but if but if but if the dollar is going
higher because capital is flowing in and
the capital is leading to higher asset
prices you can get some inflationary
effects that way too maybe it doesn't
happen as often maybe that's not the
traditional way that people think about
it but but it can happen and so if we
start to if if that starts to happen and
we start to get some inflationary
effects in the United States and this
I'm not talking tomorrow the year from
now 18 months from now two years from
now right and now it's also at the same
time causing chaos overseas or in the
less developed markets or wherever it is
and people start you know they're buying
dollars as a flight to save him but
they're not gonna put all their money in
dollars in the same way that I talked to
people in the gold world and I say well
people are gonna go to gold well of
course they're gonna go to old but
they're not gonna put all their money in
gold right they're also not gonna put
all their money in dollars they might
put a lot of it but they'll put some in
Bitcoin they'll put some in gold
they'll put some in some other safe
haven trades and I think we'll get to a
point where safe haven trades rise
together I don't think that's happening
right now because right now we're just
in the liquidation phase just like you
said just give me dollars because you
might want Bitcoin you might want gold
you might want your Rolex watch but what
you need is dollars right and so the
point I always try to make to people is
it's it's not about what people want
it's what they need you know in when you
do go down the the the pecking order you
start with what you need then you start
with what you'd like to have then you
have your dreams and your hopes and you
know but you start with your needs right
and thing is you know I would love to
see a world where where gold was a
bigger part of the financial system and
you know governments were had some
fiscal handcuffs on them and we went to
more of a true store of value where you
could measure you know with a with a
fixed yardstick how you were doing as
opposed to you know this crazy Rube
Goldberg machine that we've built
but as much as I would like that that's
not reality like the reality is is we
have central banks who print money and
we have Keynesian economics now I think
eventually we'll get to a place where we
don't but right now we do and I think
right you know as people try to escape
the system they'll go to safe havens
you know alternative forms of money
whether it's digital currencies or
whether it's Bitcoin whether it's ripple
whether it's gold
whether it's diamonds whether it's you
know seashells I don't know but I think
they will go to other things but the
dollar I think until there's a viable
alternative I think the dollars gonna
get the majority of those flows so I
think we'll get into a situation where
the dollars rising Gold's rising Bitcoin
will probably be rising or some form of
you know digital currency will be rising
and then you know it's possible that
we'll get into a situation where they
all rise together and then the dollar
falls off and that's when we roll and
that's when gold really goes through the
moon or that's when Bitcoin really goes
higher but I think right now we're still
in the liquidation phase I'm not
convinced the liquidation phase is over
well I think we're getting close but I'm
not sure that we're there yet but I
think you know I'm not ready to buy
commodities yet even if we're getting
close to the bottom of the liquidation
phase in equities I'm not sure we're to
the bottom of the liquidation phase in
commodities and that includes gold again
I think everybody should own gold I
think everybody should have some Bitcoin
I'm just not convinced they're gonna pay
off yet yeah it's really interesting to
hear kind of this idea that a safe-haven
trade kind of you must put a basket
you've got Bitcoin you've got gold and
and you also have dollars in there right
and so when you look at it as these are
all safe havens that's kind of one way
okay you could see how they could rise
together the other thing that's really
interesting is if you look at gold and
Bitcoin and kind of these alternative
currencies if you will one thing if I'm
in another country outside the United
States where a dollar is not the
dominant currency obviously yes I may
want dollars but dollars are actually
hard to get at times and can be
dangerous to get and so one of them said
you know I've talked about a lot and
thought through a lot is it actually
maybe more accessible to get gold or to
get Bitcoin or to get
some sort of alternative current and it
fits within that safe haven basket and
so you know going back to kind of the
what do people want you know well if
you're in Venezuela you probably want
out such I know you want dollars right
that is the most kind of center State or
a safe thing that you can be in it's
just really really hard to get dollars
so you have to look at other things it's
kind of like what are you mean versus
what do you want now absolutely and and
you know I I think the people that I
probably debate the most with on my
strong dollar theory or people from the
gold world and I think part of that
reason is that well number one I hope
that I've been a good advocate for gold
I think I've done a good job of
explaining to people why they should own
gold in their portfolio
I think it's disappointing to some
people in the gold world for me to then
come out and say the dollar is gonna get
stronger as well because it kind of goes
against everything that many people in
the gold world believe in right but I
kind of also think it's a really silly
argument because there's no reason you
can't own both right
you know I'm again I'm pretty vocal I
know I'm pretty vocal part of the reason
I'm very vocal is I actually want to try
to help people understand what's
actually going on in the real world not
the world that they want to exist but
the one that actually does exist and you
know in maybe in some kind of a video
game you had to choose between the two
you know then you have to choose between
dollars in gold but you know the real
world that we live in you can actually
own both you don't have to choose you
know and especially if you're not a u.s.
resident or somebody who's not
denominated in dollars by all means if I
wasn't a US dollar investor if I was in
a Canadian dollar investor or an
Australian dollar investor or you want
or yen or whatever if I was denominated
in some other currency I'd probably be
pounded in the table to buy gold as well
I just happen to be a u.s. dollar
investor in an environment where I think
the US dollars gonna get a short squeeze
right and so while that won't
necessarily kill gold I think it's at
least a headwind
to gold now that doesn't mean you
shouldn't own more than one thing in
your in the safe-haven basket there's no
reason you can't have two or three
insurance policies in fact you should
have two or three insurance policies
right so I so so so the people when I
the people that come at me really hard
and say you shouldn't have dollars you
should just have gold again I just think
it's a silly argument I'm happy to have
the argument just because I like to
argue but I think it's silly now that
make sense and then maybe let's talk a
little bit about kind of the feds
response to where we are now so we've
seen that we're in this deflationary
environment dollar strengthened in asset
prices selling off
you saw the emergency rate cuts to zero
and then you get at I have no clue what
number we end up on on the quantitative
easing side but it's going to be in the
trillions and it's gonna be big right
and so at ma two trillion orbit could be
ten trillion who knows yeah kind of what
do you think about the response so far
and then the one I keep asking was like
do they have another option it almost
feels like they're doing exactly what
they have to do to keep this going even
if we all think that it's crazy that
it's happening it's almost like they
have to do it right yeah I mean there
there's two parts to this one what are
they supposed to do and then what do
they have to do so there's a lot of
people who come out and say the feds
should do nothing they should let the
markets run themselves yes that is what
they should do you know free market and
I would love it if that world existed
that world does not exist central
bankers were created with the express
purpose of what is is going on exactly
right now they were created so that when
we get into this environment that they
can plug the hole with newly printed
money so to think that they're not going
to do it is foolish of course they're
going to do it it's just a matter of
what are the Fed what are the knock-on
effects of them doing it how successful
are they are they successful the first
time or do they have to take multiple
programs to finally get it under control
I'm convinced that they will eventually
get it under control and the dollar will
go much lower I'm also convinced they're
gonna fail before they get before
they're successful so that kind of
that's kind of a long way of answering
your question what do I think about it
now I think they're doing what they have
to do in a crisis you know when the
patient is hemorrhaging you just want to
stop the bleeding right and then you can
figure out the treatment
and that's what central bankers they're
just trying to stop the bleeding right
now they're extending swap lines they're
buying corporate bonds they're doing QE
they're cutting rates to zero again all
the countries are doing this this isn't
just the Fed they're all doing it
they're just trying to stabilize the
system and then they're gonna have and I
think what'll happen I think they will
do something it will arrest the rise of
the dollar
maybe the dollar will even fall for four
or five six months but the issue is that
you have to understand is to your point
that they're doing what they have to do
in the system that they have designed
you either print money to put more
collateral in the system off of which it
can be loaned into existence or you do
the or you just make the loans bigger
right one of those that's the way money
is created it's either physically
printed or it's loaned into existence
those are the two ways we've reached the
point where there's no more loans being
created so they're having to come in and
plug that hole
I think the hole is dramatically bigger
than anybody can conceptualize so the
fact that they're coming in and printing
I don't even know what they've done so
far it's like you know they're doing 125
billion dollars a day in repo they
promised a trillion dollars of this you
know up to two trillion dollars of that
the Congress is going to authorize two
or three trillion dollar fiscal spending
and what's the dollar done it's at its
high of three years it's barely even
backed off right and that just shows me
that the demand is so high can you
imagine a year ago if we just said
they're gonna do all this the dollar
would have fallen to 80 because nobody
believed we could get into this kind of
a dollar scramble but you know what
we're here and now that the the fuse has
been lit I think this thing's gonna
accelerate higher now it doesn't mean
there's not going to be periods of time
where they get it under control before
another fire pops up or another bomb
goes off but the bat now the battle has
started you know the battle was
simmering for a long time but now the
battle is on there's gonna be times
where one side wins and the other side
wins but I think before it's all said
and done that this dollar squeeze is
going to squeeze the dollar higher yeah
one of the questions I get so there's a
lot of people listening who will agree
with everything you just said and then
they'll say great I'm an individual how
do I play it
what are my options not so much as like
what's the advice of to go do but just
what are the options and they'll say
should I just hold dollars in my bank
account should I go and find currency
pairs and short you know something
against the dollar like what are you
kind of tell folks is just the options
we don't table it they could look at if
they're interested shirts well short
answer is there's a few different things
you can do the correct answer it kind of
depends on where you live and what your
home currency is you know and as a
general rule I would say it's kind of
the same answer for everybody but it's
also a little different I think the best
place to be over the next two or three
years is United States assets now it
doesn't mean there's not going to be
pain along the way but I think if I am
sitting in Sydney Australia and I see
what's happening to the Australian
dollar I know what the the Royal Bank of
Australia has said they're gonna do to
the Australian dollar and I know the
growth prospects for Australia pale in
comparison to to those for United States
I would rather buy coca-cola let the
Aussie dollar go down six or seven
percent collect the 4% dividend from
coca-cola there I've got a ten percent
return and if Coca Cola happens to go up
two or three percent that's all the
better right and even if it goes down 10
percent I'm still even so so you know I
think the first thing you should do is
if you're is hold dollars you know most
people in the United States we just hold
dollars because it's our natural
currency but I think if you're overseas
and especially if you have a business
that has liabilities in dollars you
should definitely hold dollars versus
your local currency that's the first
thing if you then have some excess
savings which you can deploy into US
dollar assets maybe you buy some big you
know the Dow or maybe even some
short-term Treasuries I think that would
be a good idea I think you should buy
some gold I think you should have some
Bitcoin if you could again there's kind
of a progression right if you if you
have enough liquidity to do all this
stuff maybe you do all of it but I think
the first thing you do is you know your
own just you you have your cash or your
savings and US dollars you know what
we're setting to play this now this fund
is it's only geared towards
net-worth individuals you know again I
would prefer it wasn't only for high net
worth individuals but this is these are
the regulatory requirements that have
been put down on us so it is somewhat
limited to certain individuals but to
anybody that would want to talk about
that in more detail I'm happy to talk to
them about the opportunities we see we
see incredible opportunities we're
having a lot of success and we think
we'll continue to have a lot of success
in that strategy but I think in general
I think we're still in deflation I think
we're probably going to have deflation
for a little while
on a global basis I think we're going to
continue to have deflation but in the
not-too-distant future I think we're
gonna start to see some inflationary
effects in the United States
so you know I can't really give advice
over the internet on what people should
do individually but if you kind of think
about those if you kind of think about
those dynamics maybe it gives you an
idea of how to position yourself yeah
for sure
and then last question for you before we
get into kind of the track of the hours
at the end what's your thoughts on
Bitcoin specifically Bitcoin having
coming up and kind of the macro backdrop
it's specific thoughts they're just
generally people should have it in that
safe haven blocker well I think that I
think some people would consider Bitcoin
not a safe haven they would consider it
a wild speculation I think other people
would say it's not a speculation it's a
great store of value regardless of
whether it's a great store value or pure
speculation
typically in either of those aspects the
risk return is pretty high in other
words the asymmetry of the trade is
pretty good so you know it would not
shock me at all to see Bitcoin go to
$2,000 and stay there for five years it
also wouldn't surprise me to wake up
tomorrow and find out it's $50,000 it's
that's the kind of potential it has in
both ways right I think it's in think it
has incredible potential but it's that
but because it has such a high potential
whether you like it or not whether you
hate it or not if the rest of the world
decides that bitcoin is the way to go
just the same way that currently the
world has decided that the dollar is the
way to go
bitcoins going to go a lot higher and
the you know so I think the asymmetry of
it war
having at least some exposure whether or
not and I I'm to a certain extent a
Bitcoin maximalist I think there's
actually a lot of problems with Bitcoin
I don't really have time to go into all
of my reasons right now but again
because I think others will view it as a
relative safe haven and and because I
think it's a great speculation even if
it's not a safe haven I still think I
still own some I think everybody should
own some I kind of a Bitcoin maximalist
because I think it has enough of a first
mover advantage that it would be very
hard to supplant not impossible but I
think would be very hard to supplant the
network effects are there the branding
is there all of the reasons typical
things that you see around a first mover
advantage Bitcoin I think has in spades
so I kind of like it for that reason I
don't know I don't know if I'm kind of
rambling there or not I don't know if
that answers your question but did
iiiiii I think the thing that I like
about Bitcoin and it's not quite this
way now as it was two or three years ago
I loved that it was just the wild wild
west it's pure PC it's it's big it's
coming under more regulation but for a
while it was just pure wild wild west
capitalism just raw and some people like
that and some people didn't I found it
fascinating so and I still kind of find
it fascinating so if for no other reason
I'm going to continue to follow a
Bitcoin for that aspect yeah one of the
things that's been very apparent I think
over the last kind of month or so in
this acquitting crisis is you know hours
of operations circuit breakers all these
things that are there to kind of temper
volatility and equities and in other
markets it doesn't exist in Bitcoin so
you get the you know 50% drops and then
the turnout and it's back 20% and you're
just like Jesus what is this and hey
that's a free market right that's
exactly what that is that's a free doubt
it yeah and by the way it's discovery
right right exactly what did some what's
the most important book you've ever read
The Alchemist why
you know what it's the it's the simplest
but deepest book I've ever read so you
know the there's nothing there's no
fancy words there's no there's no hard
plot there's no big mystery to it all
it's just a great story and it's
basically about you know having the guts
to go on an adventure and kind of follow
your dreams and I'm kind of a sucker for
that kind of stuff
super simple explanation and I don't
think you're wrong on that one before I
let you ask me one question to finish up
I always ask everybody about aliens
believer or non-believer Oh believer
what's the logic behind believing math
look up but there at all those stars
there are no way there's no way we're
the only one so I started asking the
question because nothing copy behind of
arrogance yeah well they think that were
the only one is it's the height of
arrogance yeah I tend to agree what one
question you have for me to finish this
up you know I want to know about you do
you do you enjoy the battle or do you
just do it because you have to because I
know you're a big you're a big believer
in what you do and you you you'll take
on the little guys you'll take on the
big guys and you know as an observer I
like it guy I kind of feel like I'm
worse we're somewhat similar in that
vein but I'm just curious whether you is
it's done out of necessity or enjoyment
yeah so it's a great question I don't
know if I have an exact answer as much
as there's an element of a lot of times
I just get frustrated when people are
blatantly saying things that are
inaccurate right and just the need to
want to correct them and say hey look
here's the the truth along with that
though I think one of the key components
to being successful especially when you
are making a very large bet on something
very early that has the kind of Aysen a
symmetry that Bitcoin has is you've got
to have really really thick skin and you
got to not be scared to kind
gage with people who have different
views and so I sometimes engage on a on
a talk track of trying to convince them
to kind of cross over or see a different
side and sometimes I basically just you
know engage because it's kind of like I
hey man I really don't care what you
think right nobody else who thinks the
same thing I think cares what you think
and so I need to tell you that yeah and
so it's very funny to get in these uh
you know it's really got Twitter and
stuff and one of the things that
somebody said to me is bitcoins like the
one asset where none of us have any
impact on it so it's not like we can
call it the CEO and ask about their
earnings report or you know literally
are just by cylinders but it continues
to outperform most other assets over
long periods of time and I think that
really really irks especially like the
equity guys and so it's always fun to
kind of you know give him a little bit
of [ __ ] and say hey look I could have
just bought this asset and hold it for
five years and I would have beat your
returns and I didn't have to do anything
yeah right and obviously you can imagine
how frustrating that is for them but
we'll see if that remains in the future
it doesn't mean that that's gonna happen
in the next five or ten years either
yeah yeah good good well I appreciate
the battle absolutely work where can
people find find you online on Twitter
and any websites or emails sure yeah I
have a website it's really just my
contact information but you're welcome
to you know go there and email me it's a
Brent at Santiago capital comm is my
email santiago capital comm website my
twitter address is at son tiago au fund
you can typically find me there i'm
pretty active and then i do a number of
podcasts i really appreciate you having
me on is it fun to talk to you and happy
to do it again absolutely well i
appreciate very much Brent we'll we'll
get this out here quickly and I think
people really gonna enjoy this one okay
awesome am good to meet you